uh and Mama knocks Erica if what do we
the public Gators need to do to help
lots of us still keep up to date with SG
Pages event style the gate companion is
there anything else we can do at this
stage
final thoughts
I think honestly
narrowing the focus on and this is no
offense to Brad but
to narrow our focus on we want Stargate
which I I've noticed some of the we want
Star dates and some of the others have
narrowed that focus a bit it's not it's
not just about the Brad Wright Canon
universe I think we separate those two
things out a little bit now and I think
what we do is we focus on supporting
gate worlds supporting sidetracks
supporting any of these that are
gathering followers supporting dial the
gate who brings in so much talent and
showrunners and writers I think is
really huge I think
honestly the best thing you can do is
get in new people that that is the the
number one thing that I am asked right
now about sci-fi is okay cool for this
franchise for this IP we've got our core
what's called your core audience we want
that next concentric circle out which
would be uh sci-fi that are overlapped
with stardate the third concentric
circle out would be things like uh
mainstream sci-fi Gamers that's what I
think genuinely you need to do as a fan
right now is expand our audience we need
to expand that fan base tell people
about dial the gate tell people about
gate world tell them that this is not
just news about what's happening or not
happening that there's amazing content
to be had tell them about the companion
about Sidetrack whomever you think is
worth following you need to expand That
Base beyond our core audience that's
honestly I know one of the first
questions that will be asked at the
table is okay cool this is great and we
love what you're doing but where are we
going to get new audiences from yeah